Speaker 1: Kari Lake was confronted by Piers
Morgan in the interview I've been waiting for for
a long time. You know, I I'm not a particularly
big fan of Piers Morgan. And in fact, his
producers have been extraordinarily unprofessional
in their dealings with me and just their lack of
organization in the discussions we've had about me
appearing with them. But this is just fantastic.
I hold no grudge and I blame him. Not at all for
that. He does a fantastic job here in confronting
failed Arizona Republican gubernatorial candidate
Carey Lake. And he's straight up says. There's no
evidence that you really won, she insists. I won.
She insists there were irregularities. My opponent
cheated. We've got lawsuits, all this different
stuff. Take a look at this and look at how
flustered she gets. Really nicely done by Piers.
Speaker 4: All right. There's been no independent
corroboration that there was anything fraudulent
about this election. In fact, it's pretty clear
that you lost to Katie Holmes. You're your rival,
50.3% to 49.6%. And as with Donald Trump and I
said, where's the hard evidence? You went down all
sorts of rabbit holes, but he couldn't produce.
Speaker 5: There's a ton of piers, Piers.
There's there's there's a mountain of hard
evidence. And when we presented it in our trial,
the other side didn't even dispute the evidence.
Speaker 1: Now, that's such a lie. It's it's
so deceptive when she says that the other side
didn't dispute the evidence. She says they
didn't need to because the so-called evidence
was nothing. It was so faulty and bogus that
a judge said, I don't even have anything here
to potentially move forward on. Remember
that they made ten complaints to a court.
Eight of the ten complaints they simply had no
grounds for whatsoever. The other two complaints,
the judge heard and said, okay, what do you have?
And the judge said, there's nothing here. It's
like if I go into court and I say bananas are
actually electric vehicles. And the judge says,
that's nonsense. We can't move forward with that.
And then I go, The other side never disputed it. I
said that bananas are elected. They never will.
No, the judge said it's so absurd. We're not
even moving forward. And Kerry likes it. But
they didn't dispute it. She is such a liar.
Speaker 5: They had.
Speaker 4: It. But not the election
result was fraudulent. You change your whole city.
Speaker 5: Yes. Well, we can't continue to run
elections this way. And we know that we won
and we're going to continue to fight this in
a court of law. And it's really rich that you're
sitting across the pond acting like, you know.
Speaker 1: You can't possibly know
whether I won. Piers, if you're in London.
Speaker 5: Happened on Election Day. I did
not see your smiling face. We had lots of
international media here covering election.
Speaker 1: It would have made no difference.
Her opponent got more votes than Arizona.
Speaker 5: Yours is one face
I didn't see and nor did I see it.
Speaker 4: You could have had my smiling
face carried Arizonans.
Speaker 5:
I would have loved to have seen you. We
had more media covering our election than
I've ever seen cover any any story here and now.
Speaker 1: And despite the record media coverage,
they still got away with
cheating. That's stunning.
Speaker 5: Kerry Zona And as I said, I covered
Arizona for nearly 30 years. So it's okay that you
are not comfortable with me fighting this election
and fighting for election integrity. No, it's.
Speaker 4: Okay. I see myself doing
that. Piers Morgan, I don't I don't
mind your fighting spirit. I don't mind
Donald Trump. I've known him a long time.
Speaker 5: Well, I have every
right to fight this election.
Speaker 1: No one's arguing it is in her right.
It's just baseless. And she's grifting, actually.
Speaker 4: Right. There does come a point.
Speaker 5: And doing this.
Speaker 2: For the benefit.
Speaker 4: Of Arizona. It does come a point when
for the future of democracy, you and Donald Trump
have to accept at some point you lost an election,
otherwise the entire system collapses. If your
simple response to losing is always we didn't
lose, we won. Then democracy dies.
Speaker 5: Pearce. I grew up in a
family of nine. I'm the youngest, my father.
Speaker 1: Well, that changes everything then.
Speaker 5: It was a history and government teacher
and a football coach, and he taught us that if we
lose and we lose fair and square, we congratulate
the winner. We walk away. And that's exactly
what I would do if that was a fair and square
election. And fighting for the people of Arizona.
Speaker 1: I mean, guys, her dad coached
football. Obviously, she wouldn't lie.
Speaker 5: Over this country. I've been
probably to six states since the election
in Arizona. I can't walk ten feet without an
Arizonan saying I voted for you. Everybody I
know voted for you. Our ballot was rejected
on Election Day. Please keep fighting for us.
I'm fighting for the people of Arizona.
Speaker 1: Every ten feet. People are
saying it was stolen. That's stunning stuff, huh?
Speaker 5: And I don't mean any offense to you,
but I frankly don't give a
damn what you think about. I'm
fighting for gay marriage. I totally am.
Speaker 4: No offense taken whatsoever.
Speaker 5: And let me ask you this, Pearce. Let
me ask let me ask you a question. Do you think
it's right that you show up on Election Day?
That's the big day on Election Day. And 60%
of the voting locations in primarily Republican
locations have ballots that are printed out wrong.
Speaker 4: This is all.
Speaker 5: Things that are genuine for our lives.
Speaker 4: Albeit from Mars.
Speaker 5: Is that okay?
Speaker 4: All I know from my lofty place
here in London, like I wasn't in Arizona.
Speaker 1: He's too far to know what happened,
guys. London's very there's water in between.
Speaker 4: Oh, is all the official fact
checking entities that I've looked into.
All the claims do not conclude.
Speaker 5: We know. You know these.
Speaker 4: Checks.
Speaker 5: Come on,
Pierce. Pierce, did you just fall off the
turnip truck? We know about the fact checkers,
and we've seen them. This is all been, guys.
Speaker 1: Despite record media coverage of
the race, the media didn't notice the
cheating by Katie Hobbs because the
media is complicit and the fact checkers
didn't notice the cheating by Haiti. Katie
Hobbs Because the fact checkers are
just left wing loons and the courts
didn't recognize Keri Lake's evidence
because the judges are left wing loons,
even though many of them are Republicans.
Speaker 5: And half of them are
leftists working for Fox.
Speaker 1: There it is.
Speaker 5: There it is. Let's be real. Okay. Okay.
Speaker 4: Let me ask you one final point.
Speaker 5: Do they know what they know?
Speaker 4: Let me ask you, Carrie. At what
point would you accept the you've lost?
Speaker 2: Never.
Speaker 5: Well, Do you think that we have a
right to move this through the court system?
Speaker 1: He already said it's not a question
of whether you have a right. Kerry.
Speaker 5: I think we do. I
know that we do. We have the right.
Speaker 4: You certainly have the right to do it.
Speaker 1: Anyway, you see the direction this is
going. She sort of has to do this because at a
certain point, if she just goes, hey, you know
what? I was wrong. I just lost. She can never
run again. And she's thinking about running for
Senate and she wants to have a political career.
So really, really nice job there by Piers
Morgan. Kerry Lake is a liar and a grifter.
And I know she doesn't really think she won.
She knows she lost, but she has to do this.